hé en grandissant, j'ai vu de première main le pouvoir
des histoires et le moment où mon
père commençait à raconter une histoire,
je me penchais instantanément et je regardais
autour de moi et je voyais que mes frères et sœurs se
penchaient et nous étions tous désespérés de
savoir ce qui allait  arriver
Disney, je dirais, a fait cela
magistralement pendant des décennies et leurs
histoires sont si classiques et si emblématiques
Maléfique Cendrillon Jungle Book et
maintenant avec des succès dragon ce sont des films
remplis d'aventure et d'espoir et de magie
quand j'ai commencé à tourner le dragon de Pete
ce que j'ai réalisé était tellement
Ce qui est puissant dans cette histoire, c'est qu'elle nous rappelle qu'il
y a cette merveille dans le monde,
il y a des choses que nous ne pouvons pas
croire qu'elles soient vraies et pourtant c'est
vous